funny because we started talking about
your relationship with your parents I'm
very curious if they find you funny not
one bit wow wow like they're proud of me
but like my mom is will be sitting like
my mom will watch the audience in the
middle of my show and therefore like I
cannot have my parents in my eye line at
all during the show I'm you know I have
to say this if I have family any kind of
family coming to a show
I can't handle it it's very difficult uh
and it could be uh you know it could be
the Chicago theater and there's whatever
000 people packed in that theater
if I know that
there's a face somewhat like mine yeah
somewhere in there uh it chills me to
the Bone I don't know what that is and
my you know my parents have been very
supportive and happy and I know they're
out there laughing but it's a kind of
pressure that's hard to explain to
people and you also take it a lot more
personally like my wife is very smart in
that on a 25 country World Tour she'll
go like okay there there and there I'm
coming with you but I'm not coming to
Arlington Texas I'll come to Edinburgh
you know I'll come to New York and so
then if you you're doing a show and you
look over in the wings and your wife is
just like on her phone
you take that so goddamn personally and
you're like I know it's the 50th time
you've seen the show but you have to be
as captive as the rest of the audience
so I just I just rather not you know
have people there I I'm just relating to
this uh
this is Meaningful to me because I know
exactly what you're talking about she's
like playing Candy Crush during my
what the hell do you see I'm killing
here he's like yeah but I'm really with
this Candy Crush this is a high score
for me this is a personal best
um tell me about that because that
intrigues me you're in a very small
uh Club of comedians that can do a world
tour and hit so many different countries
um it it that just blows me away you
thought there was a downside to having a
billion people
a billion just feels like too many to me
I've been offered a billion fans and I I
just don't find it no but I mean tell me
so what are your favorite countries to
go to or you don't have to say favorite
but where
what are the countries just say oh my
God I'm gonna absolutely kill it there
you know because you there must be spots
around the globe
um you know outside of India where you
say like oh my god when I go there it's
just at the light I like the no safety
net places and I think you you probably
relate to this uh as much in that I did
a 25 country World Tour and you know we
were in Oslo and in Oslo we maybe at
eight or nine hundred people come out
and then that was a Sunday night and
then the promoters like uh there's a
town called Stavanger which is like you
know two hours away which is a fishing
Village do you want to play Stavanger
and I'm like how many people 23. uh how
many free tickets 20. you know and it's
his friends and that's the best show of
the World Tour yeah there's no Indians
there's no safety net uh you really your
material is tested so I like that or I
like going up at the comedy seller for
instance you know following some comic
that nobody's heard of but who's 20
years in and is an assassin and so much
older than I am and and being terrified
to follow that person it's good to be
terrified it is so good to be perfect
it's awful yeah and it's also necessary
um it's funny you say that about you
know wanting to play that small
Village because I it's something that I
uh I am a little bit addicted to which
is I like to get into places where I
shouldn't be yeah you know like why is
he here it's a little bit like where's
Waldo why is that why is that guy here
and that's one of the things that uh the
minute we figured out we could start
traveling our show
um I was
Intoxicated by the idea that I could be
uh in in some strange situation in Ghana
trying to make people laugh who've never
heard of me before and uh don't really
care uh that that became I don't know
what it is there's a magic to that of
how did I get here and what are these
people going to think and
um I don't know I'm endlessly fascinated
by that and also how funny people are
the same everywhere in the world there
are a bunch of angsty you know we're
just the same Like Comics are the same
everywhere in the world that you go like
I'll try and use like a local
opener or a feature act wherever I go
and I've learned more from like local
feature acts than I have uh you know
from I think the biggest Comics anywhere
else so I love that do you do any
research and try and find out uh I
always try and find out what's the deal
with this town because there's always a
deal there's always a there's always a
oh well and I know that it can it can
seem cheap because you're playing to the
room but there's part of me that always
wants to hit on the thing that they're
thinking about which is that somebody
tried to open a knock off Walmart in
town and um but no one really likes them
and then it failed but then someone else
turned it into a Chuck E cheese that's
also a knockoff and now everybody's
happy and if you can hit on that uh and
explore that with them
um it feels kind of magical that someone
came out of the sky and landed Here and
Now is talking to you about what you're
what you care about I I like like I
think the perfect show kind of meanders
between they want to hear and
you want to say and I certainly haven't
haven't written it yet but I think in
the first five minutes you have to find
something some sort of local
acknowledgment of where both here and I
have in some sense experienced your city
because it's disingenuous not to yeah so
like I will kind of go in a little bit
earlier and do one thing so if you're on
Stavanger I will try the fish soup and
and have you know jokes about that